107 and a half per game  by defensive rating their best in the  NBA Grizzlies forced a turnover Morant  back the other way and now Brooks and  Middleton get into it and they are  separated and well I'll tell you what  happened partner is great defense by  Dylan Brooks as Chris Middleton went to  the floor Dylan went to step over and  start to run down the floor Chris  Middleton trips Dylan Brooks as he gets  ready to run down the floor I don't have  an opportunity to see what happens  you'll see a great defense they go to  the floor here and they say he's  grabbing the leg there yeah and they  look there that's a that is just a  takedown by Middleton yeah so now we're  going to go to the replay center tonight  because I would imagine you would have  to this is certainly a hostile Act  so you want to know who's in the replay  Center tonight